[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend es war ein antrittsbesuch
und der wurde mit anstand absolviert von
beiden seiten außenministerin annalena
baerbock ist am abend aus moskau
zurückgekehrt wo sie mitten in dem sich
zuspitzenden konflikte an der
ukrainischen grenze die russische
haltung ausloten ansätze zum dialog
finden wollte und zumindest nicht ab
letzte
russland setzt derweil aber auf fakten
militärische fakten entlang des
grenzverlaufs zur ukraine sind
inzwischen mehr als 100 soldaten
aufgefahren gefechts übungen seien das
meer nicht hieß es auch heute wieder
diese kulisse mein berbalk könne die
ukraine
nur als drohung empfinden es ist eine
die sich an den gesamten westen richtet
der nun fieberhaft versucht russland zum
einlenken zu bewegen wie weit die
deutsche außenministerin dabei heute kam
axel stein
hier kommt man ihr sehr nahe der deutsch
russischen geschichte am grabmal des
unbekannten soldaten im alexander garten
in moskau der verhängnisvollen der
leidvollen geschichte aber auch der
hoffnungsvollen die neue deutsche
außenministerin geschichts und
selbstbewusst der kranz das schweigen
stille minuten heute
danach gespräche mit dem gesicht der
russischen außenpolitik ihrem kollegen
sergej lavrov in hoch brisanter zeit
in den letzten wochen haben sich mehr
als hundert tausend russische soldaten
mit panzern und geschützen der nähe der
ukraine versammelt ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund und es ist
schwer das nicht als drohung zu
verstehen
wir haben erklärt dass es keine
eskalation gibt von der westliche
politiker derzeit sprechen
gemeint ist die präsenz unserer eigenen
truppen auf dem eigenen territorium und
die durchführung notwendiger schritt
gefechtsausbildung
unveränderte positionen und verzerrtes
werben für den dialog bei baerbock denn
das war es was die journalistinnen und
journalisten wissen wollten
kann sie anbieten nach der vergangenen
woche krisendiplomatie in sachen ukraine
aus unserer sicht wichtig den normandie
prozess wieder mit leben zu füllen um
endlich bei der implementierung der
minsker vereinbarung voranzukommen es
gebe viel gemeinsames trotz der
russischen drohkulisse mit ihrer
normandie idee gesprächen also zwischen
moskau kiew paris und berlin läuft sie
keine weit offenen türen ein aber sie
läuft auch nicht gegen verschlossener
diese bilder sozusagen begleitmusik
russische soldaten bei rostov am don
taktischen übungen rund 100 kilometer
von der ukrainischen grenze entfernt
auch für die kameras behält russland den
druck bei und im westen diskutiert man
weiter mahnt man weiter sucht nach
möglichen sanktionen und war eine
militärische aggression gegen die
ukraine würde schwerwiegende politische
wie auch wirtschaftliche konsequenzen
nach sich ziehen deshalb ist es unsere
aufgabe alles dafür zu tun dass eine
solche entwicklung vermieden werden kann
es sind wirklich erschreckende
nachrichten die wir dort bekommen und
selbst im kalten krieg war die
gefährlichkeit der situation nicht zu
hoch wie sie jetzt ist die neue deutsche
außenministerin war heute morgen in
moskau vor den schwierigen politischen
gesprächen in der berühmten tretjakow
galerie die ausstellung heißt vereinte
vielfältigkeit ein titel der mehr als
ein wunsch sein dürfte vielerorts in
diesen zeiten
und die westliche dialog offensive geht
weiter die nato hat neue gespräche
vorgeschlagen morgen wird der
amerikanische außenminister blinken nach
kiel fahren und nach einer abstimmung
mit den europäern am donnerstag in
berlin am freitag seinen russischen
kollegen in genf treffen ist russland so
zu zähmen sigmar gabriel ehemaliger spd
vorsitzender ehemaliger
bundesaußenminister heute vorsitzender
der atlantik-brücke schön gut nahm nach
goslar
im nordosten gabriel zum dialog gibt es
keine alternative diesen satz hat
berbalk heute so ein bisschen ins
schaufenster gestellt und gesprochen
wird jetzt viel aber reicht das vor
allem welche sprache versteht russland
natürlich hat vorburg absolut recht es
gibt keine dir keine alternative zum
dialog aber needs to tango also es muss
sozusagen auch auf der anderen seite
gesprächsbereitschaft gehen und was wir
bislang gesehen haben dass erstens eine
wirklich unfassbare drohgebärde mit über
100.000 soldaten an der grenze zur
ukraine
und zweitens sätze des stellvertretenden
russischen aussenministers bei der man
den eindruck haben muss dass krieg ein
denkbares mittel der russischen politik
geworden ist und deswegen finde ich das
zuerst mal die russen gefragt werden
müssen was sie bereit sind zu
deeskalieren denn die eskalation geht ja
nicht weder von der ukraine aus noch von
der europäischen union den usa oder der
nato
was haben die europäer denn in der hand
um druck zu machen um diese antwort auch
zu erhalten jetzt haben wir ja so einen
sanktionskatalog durchaus auf dem tisch
da gehört jetzt offenbar ernsthaft der
ausschluss aus zwölf diesem europäischen
zahlungssystems schon gar nicht mehr
dazu jedenfalls mehren sich warnende
stimmen dazu gehört auch nicht eine aus
für nord stream zwei das hat
bundeskanzler scholz vom tisch genommen
weil er sein rein privatwirtschaftliches
projekt sei dieses nord stream 2 es
mangelt irgendwie auch an konsequenz
erstmal muss man feststellen dass
offensichtlich die europäische union am
katzentisch sitzen das finde ich
deswegen für die ich es ja gut dass vor
der burg hingefahren ist denn die
amerikaner verhandeln mit den russen
über die lage in europa das ist für
einen überzeugten europäer schon einmal
ein schwaches bild das die europäische
union insgesamt abgibt das heißt das
erste wäre mal dass die eu eine
gemeinsame handlungs position einnimmt
das zweite ist da wir weder wir noch die
usa in einen militärischen konflikt mit
russland gehen wollen bleiben nur
wirtschaftliche sanktionen und
allerdings davon gibt es eine ganze
menge möglichkeiten man muss den preis
für eine militärische aktion den russen
auch sagen ich meine wir sprechen hier
über krieg oder einen möglichen krieg in
der europäischen in europa das ist ein
so unglaublicher vorgang dass man da
auch den russen sagen was was das am
ende kostet die europäer schon eine
ganze reihe an möglichkeiten aber
dazugehört sie hätten die möglichkeit
mit nord stream zwei durchaus eine
drohkulisse aufzubauen das aus nämlich
im grunde
anzukündigen für den fall dass die
ukraine über fallen würde aber das ist
eben vom tisch ich will da noch mal
konkret nachfragen ist das richtig oder
muss es nicht zum sanktionskatalog
also ich habe heute aufmerksam zugehört
und habe das gegenteil gehört nämlich
dass der deutsche bundeskanzler olaf
scholz erklärt hat was alles auf dem
tisch liegt natürlich ist auch jedem
klar dass im falle eines militärischen
angriffs der russlands auf die ukraine
kein mensch daran denken kann nord
stream zwei zu beenden oder dem
fortzuführen ich meine befürchtungen
dass die russen das wissen und das
solche sanktionsmaßnahmen möglicherweise
gar nicht ausreichend weil es so eine
art großmacht steuer ist die in russland
längst eingeplant dass deswegen sind die
amerikanischen hinweise auf swift und
andere ist natürlich deutlich
drastischer aber das nord stream zwei
nicht im betrieb kommen kann wenn
russland einen krieg gegen die ukraine
für das ist so selbstverständlich dass
es fast nicht lohnt darüber zu reden
jetzt wird russland positiv zur kenntnis
genommen haben dass deutschland
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine nach
wie vor ablehnt anders als
großbritannien das jetzt die lieferung
von panzern abwehrwaffen zur zur
selbstverteidigung der ukraine zugesagt
hat wie glaubwürdig ist es ja gabriel
das selbstbestimmungsrecht der ukraine
jahr deutlich zu betonen ihr aber hilfe
zu verweigern und dann andere zu
verweisen
naja es gibt ja hilfe durchaus bei der
ausbildung der ukrainischen
selbstverteidigung auch der armee aber
es gibt eben einen grundsatz in
deutschland an dem würde ich auch nicht
rütteln und der lautet keine waffen in
kriegen krisengebiete und in denkbare
kriegsgebiete zu liefern weil wir
glauben dass die mittel der diplomatie
längst nicht ausgeschöpft sind ich
glaube dass das eine vernünftige haltung
in deutschland ist das sehen andere
anders auch die amerikaner aber ich kann
nur daran erinnern es gab schon mal eine
solche aktion bei der kurz davor war das
schwere waffen in die ukraine geliefert
werden als russland damals die krim
annektiert hat und in der ost ukraine
sozusagen ein bürgerkrieg unterstützt
hat damals sind die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und der
französische präsident francois hollande
nach moskau und nach kiew geflogen und
haben letztlich durchsetzen können dass
eine eskalation nicht kommt das noch mal
die format das jetzt wiederbelebt werden
soll ist ja damals entstanden das
keineswegs so dass man jetzt schon davon
ausgehen muss dass es keine chance mehr
gibt aber noch einmal der preis für
krieg in europa der muss klar sein ich
bin wie sie wissen jemand der immer für
entspannung mit russland gewesen ist ich
bin auch immer ein vertreter von nord
stream gewesen aber bei krieg ist
sozusagen jeder fan ums bereitschaft zu
ende und das müssen die russen wissen
sagt sigmar gabriel frühere
bundesaußenminister dankeschön nach
goslar
so die
bei ihrem besuch heute in moskau
erinnerte die deutsche außenministeriums
eingangs gesehen an die millionen
sowjetischen opfer der nazidiktatur die
nicht vergessen würden mit dem deutschen
einmarsch in die sowjetunion im sommer
1941 begann der systematischen mord an
den juden europas das töten lief bereits
als im januar vor 80 jahren die wannsee
konferenz abgehalten wurde im kreis
hoher verwaltungsbeamter ging es an
diesem zwanzigster januar 1942 längst
nicht mehr darum das morden zu
beschließen sondern es zu optimieren
der bundespräsident besuchte heute den
historischen ort an dem mit deutscher
gründlichkeit ein völkermord geplant
wurde
es ist ein idyllischer ort die villa am
berliner wannsee es ist ein ort der
täter
1942 lädt reinhard heydrich ss ober
gruppenführer spitzenbeamte des
deutschen reiches 1 bei besprechung mit
anschließendem frühstück organisieren
die 15 männer hier die massen
vernichtung der europäischen juden
deborah hartmann leitet die gedenkstätte
als erste frau als jüdin
ich glaube dass gerade dieser ort hier
wurde diese besprechung
deutlich machen wie antisemitische
vorstellungen in verbindung mit moderner
bürokratie in die tat umgesetzt werden
wir wissen durchaus dass der dass das
die gesamten verwaltungsinstanz genau
ganz bürokratisch sauber administrativ
die deportationen und den massenmord
letztlich abgewickelt und abgefertigt
haben eine dauerausstellung in der
gedenkstätte spiegelt den horror besuch
des bundespräsidenten und seiner frau am
abend bei der premiere des zdf
spielfilms die wannseekonferenz erinnert
er an die bürokratische kaltblütigkeit
des massenmordes
in unserem staat in unserem
demokratischen staat trägt jeder
einzelne verantwortung
sollen wir die verantwortung nicht auch
nicht die nein zu sagen wo es recht und
mitmenschlichkeit gebieten der spielfilm
beschreibt die nüchterne planung des
grauens etwa der gaskammern
für unsere eigenen männer beschränkt
sich die tätigkeit im grunde auf das
sicherstellen geordnete abläufe sowie
das freisetzen der nötigen gas aber der
anblick dieser vielen toten den
transport zu den höfen wird erfolgen
durch arbeits juden die wiederum
schlussendlich ebenfalls sonder
behandelt werden elegant im spielfilm
haben wir uns immer wieder die frage
gestellt wie kann man eine konferenz von
15 verantwortungsträgern in cannes
technokraten deutsche darstellen die
über was ganz ungeheuerliches reden und
begreift unsere publikum waren die
jüngeren auch diese banalität des bösen
das gewöhnliche und auch der verrat in
diesem schreiben im haus der
wannsee-konferenz denunziert eine frau
ihre jüdischen nachbarin an die gestapo
wo das zeigt ja gerade in diesem haus
hier dass wir auch ein bischen wegrücken
müssen den fokus von diesen 15 männern
also diesen 15 teilnehmern der
wannseekonferenz
sondern eigentlich den blick weiten
müssen also wer hat eigentlich diesen
massenmord überhaupt erst ermöglicht
unmöglich gemacht es waren die menschen
nahezu ein ganzes land ein
erschütternder blick zurück das erinnern
wichtig für die zukunft
die wannseekonferenz der film läuft
nächsten montag im zdf programm und seit
heute bereits in der zdf mediathek
und unter zdf.de finden sie zudem ein
großes informationspaket mit vielen
aspekten zur wannseekonferenz sein
angebot gegen geschichtsvergessenheit
und nun zunächst nachrichten mit gundula
gause die weltgesundheitsorganisation
hat eindringlich vor einer verharmlosung
der omicron variante des corona virus
gewarnt wie hfg places erklärte omikron
möge im durchschnitt weniger
schwerwiegend sein aber koste leben in
deutschland registrierte das
robert-koch-institut
74 1405 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 28
1715 mehr als vor einer woche
193 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage ins ident steigt weiter an auf nun
553 2
zugleich bleibt die hospitalisierung
rate niedrig laut lka sind auf 100.000
einwohner binnen einer woche der zeit
3,17 corona patienten in kliniken ende
november lag die rate bei knapp 13 in
der pandemie haben sich menschen
radikalisiert die nicht rechts oder
links zu verorten sind das zeigt die
statistik zu politisch motivierten
straftaten des bundeskriminalamtes nach
vorläufigen daten bilanziert das bka
eine zunahme im vergangenen jahr um 6
prozent auf 47
1300 delikte davon werden 40 prozent dem
rechten spektrum zugeschrieben 20% dem
linken mehr als jede dritte tat sei
ideologisch nicht zu verorten
neue präsidentin des europäischen
parlaments ist die christdemokraten
roberta mit sole aus malta sie folgt auf
den überraschend verstorbenen
sozialdemokratischen präsidenten soli
aus italien die an ihrem 43 geburtstag
mit absoluter mehrheit gewählte juristin
ist die dritte frau und auch die jüngste
an der parlamentsspitze der wechsel der
präsidentschaft war ohnehin zwischen
konservativen und sozialdemokraten
vereinbart worden mit solar gilt als
kämpferin gegen korruption und für
frauenrechte
die bundesregierung hat im vergangenen
jahr rüstungsexporte für 93 5 milliarden
euro genehmigt und damit mehr als je
zuvor nach vorläufigen zahlen des
wirtschaftsministeriums ist
empfängerland nummer eins ägypten die
neue bundesregierung will wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart die
rüstungsexporte mit einem kontrollgesetz
einschränken
erstmals hat ein katholischer bischof
als zeuge vor einem deutschen gericht in
einem missbrauchsprozess ausgesagt der
hamburger erzbischof stefan hesse wurde
vor dem landgericht köln im fall eines
angeklagten heute 70 jährigen pfarrers
befragt der seine nichten missbraucht
haben soll es räumte als zeuge heute ein
als damaliger personalchef im erzbistum
köln in dem fall fehler gemacht zu haben
ein urteil wird ende februar erwartet
wenn nicht gerade corona ist findet im
januar üblicherweise die grüne woche in
berlin statt ein branchentreffen mit
allem was es und trinkbar ist und ein
pflichttermin für jeden
landwirtschaftsminister der sich dann
mit festem magen durch die hallen essen
muss ein 23 schnäpschen inclusive all
das bleibt den neuen agrarminister cem
özdemir erspart er heute in ganz
nüchtern im rahmen zusammen mit
umweltministerin lemke die geplante
grüne agrarwende vorstellte hochwertige
aber bezahlbare lebensmittel bessere
einkommen für landwirte mehr tierwohl
mehr umwelt- und klimaschutz die ziele
sind ehrgeizig und vorgänger sind daran
schon gescheitert oliver deuker mit
einem realitätscheck aus deutschen
landen
will tewes aus der nähe von hannover die
extrem niedrigen schweinepreise der
vergangenen jahre gefährden seine
ferkelzucht mit 700 frauen jetzt in der
tier wohl zu investieren die ist die
bundesregierung will ist finanziell
nicht so einfach machbar wir stellen
gerne unsere betriebe um die meisten
landwirte sind bereit veränderungen in
kauf zu nehmen und dort auch zu
investieren gerade auch im bereich
tierschutz aber das ganze muss
wirtschaftlich sein wir müssen geld
verdienen das ist unser beruf so sieht
es auch geografisch 700 mastbullen und
kälbchen stehen in seinen ställen bei
hannover mal so eben umbauen und möglich
wenn jetzt etwas geändert wird ohne dass
man uns die möglichkeit der wirtschaft
erwirtschaften der investition gibt dann
brauchen wir natürlich übergangsfristen
oder finanzielle unterstützung das
wissen die neuen die grünen
bundesumweltministerin steffi lemke und
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister cem
özdemir in der in ihre reformpläne beim
agrar kongress die zeit ist reif
landwirtschaft natur umwelt klimaschutz
unter einen hut endlich zu bekommen ich
setze mich dafür ein dass wir bessere
rahmenbedingungen sind für unsere
bäuerinnen und bauern für die gehaltenen
tiere aber eben auch für umwelt und für
klimaschutz bekommen eine
rahmenbedingungen wir eine umverteilung
bei den flächen subventionen wie ssd
mehr will bisher bekommen die großen
betriebe viel geld die klein wenig
beklagt auch biobauer johannes erkens
aus der nähe von hannover in die gibt es
ja schon länger scheitert immer in
brüssel ich finde das alles betrifft für
mich besonders wichtig weil wir sind
flächenmäßig anja sehr kleiner betrieb
dir eine flächenprämie müsste ganz klar
gedeckelt sein und ist absolut nicht
mehr zeitgemäß
30 fleischrinder und 6000 legen hat der
biobetrieb überwiegend direktvermarktung
die zahlen stimmen kunden die hier
einkaufen zahlen den realen wert des
produktes ramschpreise gibt es hier
nicht haben will sollte dafür sorgen
dass den verbrauchern ihr lebensmittel
was sie täglich essen mehr wert ist und
dass dadurch der die die wertigkeit der
produkte von deutschen landwirten steigt
und dadurch auch gern genommen wird und
dann kann auch wenn der preis stark sich
auch einiges ändern und kann man auch
eine menge umbauen weil es kostet nun
mal geld ob das alles funktioniert
geografisch hat da seine zweifel denn
die gerade festgelegten ziele der eu
agrarpolitik sind deutlich weniger
ambitioniert als es die us pläne also
ich die probleme des wettbewerbs die
dazu führen werden dass noch mehr
lebensmittel möglicherweise günstigere
lebensmittel zu anderen bedingungen
produziert aus dem ausland nach
deutschland kommen und unsere produkte
finden keinen absatz
agrarprodukte teurer aber auch
tiergerechter und klima und umwelt
schonen da produziert am ende
entscheidet aber der kunde ob es ihm das
wert ist bisher geben die deutschen
verglichen mit anderen industriestaaten
weniger geld für lebensmittel aus
eine branche die in der pandemie einen
enormen aufschwung erlebt ist die
industrie der videospiele da gab es
heute eine milliardenschwere ankündigung
interessant nicht nur für spieler kunde
da sondern auch für anleger der
software-riese microsoft will für fast
70 milliarden dollar den spieleanbieter
activision blizzard kaufen nach apple
ist microsoft das zweitwertvollste
unternehmen weltweit cantica spieler und
anleger zeigen sich begeistert frank
bethmann was steckt denn hinter dieser
bislang teuersten übernahme in der
digitalen welt na ja zunächst mal
microsoft macht mit dieser mega
übernahme einen weiteren riesensatz in
die virtuelle 3d spiele welt ein markt
der insbesondere in corona zeiten
zugelegt hat nachfrage nach videospielen
ist enorm geschätzt spielen heute etwa
drei milliarden menschen rund um den
globus auf smartphones konsolen und pcs
mit blockbustern wie call of duty candy
crash oder world of warcraft gehört
activision blizzard zu den größten
herstellern von computerspielen doch
hinter dem deal steckt noch viel mehr
sagen analysten die übernahme von
activision gilt als schlüssel für den
einstieg von microsoft um das ganz große
thema das da heißt metaversum das
metaversum wird von it-spezialisten als
zukunft des internets gesehen es steht
für einen virtuellen 3d raum in dem alle
teilnehmer vernetzt sind sich
austauschen und zb über virtual reality
brillen miteinander spielen große
konzerne sind in diesen virtuellen welt
nun endlich es potenzial für neue märkte
als erster grosser tag gigant hatte
facebook den einstieg ins metaversum zum
neuen über thema erklärt und sich sogar
in meta umbenannt nun also folgt mit
microsoft der zweite big player noch ist
das ganze mehr halber hype als alles
andere doch offenbar ist die sorge groß
ein milliarden geschäft zu verpassen
frank bethmann vielen dank
ein schwerer schneesturm hat im osten
der usa strom und flugausfälle
verursacht die us bundesstaaten georgia
virginia north und south carolina waren
besonders stark betroffen tausende flüge
wurden anulliert schneechaos auch auf
den straßen zudem kam es an der ostküste
zu überschwemmungen aktuell erwartet der
us wetterdienst eine abmilderung des
schneesturms
zum sport bei den australian open ist
angelique kerber ausgeschieden eine
bittere erstrunden niederlage an ihrem
34 geburtstag gegen die esten kanepi
damit steht erstmals seit
1977 keine deutsche mehr in der zweiten
runde dieses tennisturniers und im dfb
pokal läuft das achtelfinale mit
auswärtssiegen haben bereits der
karlsruher sc und der hsv das
viertelfinale erreicht karlsruhe gewann
bei 1860 münchen und der hamburger sv in
einem pokal-krimi beim favorisierten
bundesligisten erst der fc köln im
elfmeterschießen ja
normalerweise entscheidet im sport
allein die leistung wer den sieg
davonträgt bei der gerade laufenden
handball-em kommt noch etwas hinzu wer
kann am besten corona trotzen neun mal
positiv nur noch ein torwart so stand
das deutsche team plötzlich da und dann
wurde nach gefüttert und ersatz
eingeflogen und das mit erfolg
deutschland zieht mit einem sieg über
polen in die hauptrunde ein eine
grandiose sportliche trotzreaktion
aber man kann das alles auch ihr sinnen
thomas skulski aus bratislava
am vormittag stand der noch vor
verschlossener tür mannschaftshotel acht
stunden später im tor der deutschen
handballer und wäre johannes bitter
nicht nach bratislava gekommen sie
hätten kein toter mehr gehabt keine
hauptberuflichen am abend 9 corona fälle
obwohl sie unter sich sind isoliert in
den oberen beiden etagen ihres hotels
das problem wird darin liegen dass wir
irgendwann mal zwischen testen und
befunden einfach zu lange zeit hatten
und im prinzip die person die das
erstmalig ins team gebracht hat war
völlig raus nehmen konnten wie sinnvoll
möchte man fragen ist eine solche em in
einer sportart der der kontakt zum
gegner dazu gehört wie die tore
die sinnhaftigkeit haben wir nicht
hinterfragt wir waren total fokussiert
und haben gesagt dass wir das auch für
die jungs die jetzt erkrankt sind
gewinnen wollen nicht dass du trotz
macht man sich natürlich sorgen klar
sind frage kann man stellen ich bin aber
der meinung dass es ja irgendwie
weitergehen muss und dann denke ich es
ist viel schöner das so und mit sehr
extremen maßnahmen als garmisch das 30
zu 23 ein trotziges jetzt erst recht
weil julian köster der 21-jährige aus
der zweiten liga immer trifft wenn er
wirft sechs tore und spieler des spiels
bei christoph stein hat auch er
turnier-neuling sicher beiden
siebenmeter ist alle sechs der
verwandelt neun tore insgesamt an seinem
32 geburtstag und weil die abwehr super
arbeitet deutschlands bestes spiel
bislang im turnier
ich glaube die jungs die nachgerückt
sind sie sind alle schon ein bisschen
erfahrener die haben vom kalender spiele
auf dem buckel die wissen wie das ganze
läuft sie trotzen den ausfällen doch wer
einreist reist ins risiko aus der
bundesliga kommt der gedanke deutschland
könne sich auch von der em zurückziehen
bei weiteren corona fällen die spieler
die hier sind sind da anderer meinung
und man wünschte ihnen dass sie negativ
bleiben zu viele von uns in unserem
heute journal update spricht wulf
schmiese mit norwegens regierungschef
zur erdgas versorgung in deutschland
jetzt schon zu sehen auf zdf heute und
hier später nur 20 und noch mehr gutes
programm jetzt im anschluss bei 37 grad
geht es um eltern von straßenkindern und
ihren kampf sie wieder zurück in die
familie zu holen er eindringlich tschüss
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt nimmt der winter
wieder etwas fahrt auf denn das hoch
dieter verabschiedet sich richtung
südosten und zwischen dem tief wieder
und dem hoch erich kommt jetzt
wenigstens vorübergehend mal wieder
etwas kältere luft zu uns das bedeutet
es fällt schnee nicht nur auf den
berggipfeln heute nacht allerdings fällt
noch kein schnyder ist es meist bedeckt
und es bildet sich auch wieder nebel die
temperaturen sinken in norddeutschland
auf 3 bis 1 grad im süden wird es
deutlich kälter am kältesten am
alpenrand mit -8 kraft und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 1 grad
in den westlichen mittelgebirgen und
maximal 7 grad auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und auch morgen gibt es erstmal
wieder nebel dann aber auch sonnenschein
jedenfalls in der südosthälfte aber von
nordwesten kommt diese kaltfront heran
die bringt regen mit und in den
westlichen mittelgebirgen kann es schon
mittags für schneeregen reichen dann
wird's auch glatt spannend wird dann
aber die nacht auf donnerstag wenn es
nämlich nicht mehr nur in den
mittelgebirgen schneit sondern auch im
flachland der donnerstag wird dann ein
sehr ungemütlicher wintertag mit immer
wieder schnee schnee regen und
graupelschauern es kann sogar kurze
gewitter dabei sein und am längsten
schneit es hier am erzgebirge oder auch
am alpenrand das wird also ein
ungemütlicher donnerstag der freitag
wird schon ruhiger aber am samstag
schneit es dann vor allen dingen wieder
am alpenrand guten abend